,
station balnéaire réputée
de corail, est une destination
priséeouristes
durant la période hivernale.
Mais une fusillade,
cette fois-ci, au complexe
au Sud de Cancún, vient
rir le portrait.
Le principal suspect est
canadien. Il a fait feu
hier après-midi, à l'intérieurd.
Les trois victimes, aussi
des Canadiens, ont été l'hôpitùu
deux d'entre eux sont morts
des suites de leurs blessures.
Ils auraient tous
des antécédents otamment au trac
d'armes et de drogues.
Le tireur était aussi connu
des policiers. Les autorités
mexicaines ont d'ailleurs relayé
sa phoeurent toujours
à sa recherche.
Affaires mondiales a réagi
à l'incident. Les agentsisent en
communication avec les autorités
locales et se tiennent prêts à
fournir toute forme de souxiques
les plus dangereux au mond
avec une moyenne de 91 meurtres
par jour.
En no
avait fait deux morts sur
la plato Morelos,
près de Cancún.
Et à la fin un blogueur
californien et un Allemand, ont
été tués alors qu'ils avaient
été pris entre les feux croisés
de traroulx,
Radio-Canada, M